And yeah, first I want to tell you a little bit about myself. My name is Marcus. I'm hugely interested in Jung, and I started to read all the stuff that is practically available, and I read now almost everything that's available except for the books that cost €500.
I read the Collected Works, seminars, letters, the autobiography, The Red Book, and interviews and a whole lot of books. Jung was very prolific and wrote a lot. And through reading that, I met a lot of people who were interested in the concepts, but they're very hard to get into.
And so I want to help people to get a better understanding about Jung because he talks about a lot of things and he talks about a lot of difficult things. So it's a good way to jumpstart. And just get some basics down. And when you have those, then Jung is really amazing, incredibly interesting topics. Otherwise you wouldn't be here.
And this is, yeah, my way also to learn a little bit more and understand it better because the best way to learn something is trying to teach others. This is now my attempt. So I started this group beginning of the year and now we're going very strong over 320 members. And a couple of events ago, I started podcasts. It also is going well.
So all indicators look good. And the events are always structured in that way that I give a presentation about the topic. And afterwards, there's this Q&A discussion part to get more into detail and to discuss a little bit more about Jung. So.
About Jung himself, also as an introduction, uh, C.G.
Jung was a Swiss psychologist, lived from 1875 to 1961, lived a long life, lived a productive life, wrote incredibly difficult books till pretty much the end of his life, and is a very famous figure of psychology, was himself very well-regarded and also published scientist and came in that way in contact with Freud, who started the whole field of psychoanalysis.
And they both were very close, but only for a couple of years. Then they, ah, settle out of their friendship, and Jung went in a very interesting way. Uh, he went in a way to say, okay, everything that human beings are experiencing and producing gives an indication how the psychology works. Everything is valid.
So he delves into a lot of spiritualism, occultism, religion, mythology, and so on. And this is what many people also know of Jung and what makes him interesting because he takes it all incredibly serious and tries to understand, okay, why are human beings coming up with this and where is the interest coming from that sustains this?
Because we have myths that we still tell today, but are thousands of years old. At least that's what we know. Most likely they're even older. And he talked about a wide array of different topics. And one very big one is Psychological Types. And it's so big that he wrote a book about it that's called Psychological Types.
For those of you who are reading the Collected Works, this is number 6, and it's one complete, very thick book that he wrote over roughly 8 years, and he published it in 1921 when he was 45 years old.
And he drew really from his experience of roughly 20 years of psychological work and academic work and therapy also to characterize people, to find certain orientations of functions, how he has called it, that are the same over all human beings.
And this is already a way to approach personality and to characterize personality, and Jung was one of the first to do it in such big detail.
And this is an interesting book because the first part of it is very long, 100, 150 pages, where he takes different psychological personality models from the past, from, I think it was Aristotle, but also Schiller and other people to find commonalities between them.
It's a little bit like a meta-analysis of different models that existed in the past. And from those, he distilled those two types of orientation that human beings can have, which is extraversion and introversion, both terms coined by Carl Gustav Jung.
He is the father of those terms and also of the definitions, which are a little bit different than what it's understood today, but they are similar enough to pretty much get the gist just from the name. So, in this time, in the 8 years that he wrote it, he published nothing else. He worked on some side projects like The Red Book, which went unknown for, for many, many years.
But in that time, he really focused on writing this down. And this is one of the books that Jung is famous for and academia.
And the book with the Psychological Types is also the basis for the Myers-Briggs inventory, which is famous in America, especially for personality tests. And there is a certain big overlap, but also differences to Myers-Briggs.
I'm not so competent in Myers-Briggs, but yeah, for those who are, like Philip, they can point out then the differences and the commonalities later. So to start with the Psychological Types, we have to first understand a little bit about the Jungian view of the psyche.
And for Jung, in the center of the psyche It's pretty much the ego. In German, das Ich, in English, ego, which is the center of experience. So what you are experiencing in your daily life, you do it from the position of the ego.
And when you get unconscious because you're drunk or you're sleeping, it's just the ego not getting any more information. That's the way how Jung saw it and The main question, of course, is then when you have the ego and around it forming the consciousness by having things that associated with the ego.
So everything that you know and can do and have experienced is a question. Okay, how does stuff get to the ego? Because it's a pretty big world out there and there's a lot to experience. And Jung saw certain channels, how information reaches the ego and thus the awareness that one then can have of things.
And he found those four functions that would describe different ways how information reaches the ego. And, uh, I'm gonna tease a little more and start talking first about another thing, which is just a general orientation. That you can have in the world.
And here already this extraversion and introversion comes into play, as you can have for Jung an orientation either to the outside world, to everything that's happening around you in the real physical world, so to say, and the introversion, which means to look inside and more be more aware of the psychological realm and things that are happening internally.
And I see these terms coined by Jung, dichotomy, as they have other points of interest and points of focus. So he very often just describes this as really a comparison, as they're moving on a spectrum and, uh, two extremes of a similar spectrum.
And This extraversion, I'm, I'm not trying to say extroverted because I don't want to give the impression that this is just a mode of being completely, but rather let's say an extroverted view would be to have the strong view into the world and this view into objects.
And he contrasts this with the introvert who is, uh, focused on the subject, so on subjective experience, while the extraverted person would be rather looking outside into objects. And the extraverted view for Jung would be also a very detailed empirical view.
He would say that extraverts would have, um, a very good empirical understanding as they would rather look into details and see, um, like fine-grained differences. While an introverted view is rather an abstraction to find more commonalities and describe things rather how they compare to others and find commonalities with other things.
While an extraverted view would be to really separate into discrete, unique units of something. And extravert would rather, of course, orientate themselves in the world and see the world as something friendly.
Carl Gustav Jung describes this as a big family, that the extravert would rather see the world as a big family, as something that is not moving by itself, but needs to be moved, but it's always friendly. While the introverted view is the other side of the spectrum to say the world is moving a lot and it's moving all by itself. And that's a rather frightening thing.
So a lot that Jung describes as introverted behavior, it's kind of protection against this free moving outside world that everything happens by itself.
And this is why for Jung, the introvert is rather looking for stability and harmony, while the extravert would rather have a lot of dynamics, a lot of changes, a lot of variation.
And it is this preference for the outside and this enthusiasm to be outside that for Jung means that the extravert is constantly communicating their personality with that they can't really do anything about. It's just how they are.
They want to exert personality and rather the whole demeanor is relaxed while introvert is more tense and would rather like to have impersonal communication and rather than talking themselves, let the work talk and is in that sense also more tense and careful behaving.
And this is modes of operation and where the preference lies for Jung. So this is just, um, to get the general gist of the concepts. I will go later more deeply in how it relates to other concepts, but because there will be some for today. So this is orientation rather if there's a preference into the external world or the internal world.
To come back to these channels where information can come from, Jung said he found 4 and he can't think of any more. And I will give you a quote to give you a feeling what exactly he meant. And these 4 channels are sensation, thinking, feeling, and intuition. And his quote goes like this: Sensation establishes what is actually present.
Thinking enables us to recognize its meaning. Feeling tells us its value. And intuition points to possibilities as to whence it came and whether it's going to in a given situation. Okay. I botched that quote.
And here he already has this pathway of information, how it reaches the ego and the psyche. And how it will change. So the first one is really this sensation aspect of realizing there is something happening. And all of those functions can be applied either to externally or internally.
I can notice that something in the outside is changing, but also I can internally feel something like an emotion. Emotion comes up and just recognizing this, this goes a little bit in this mindful aspect. This is quite popular today or currently.
And this sensation aspect is really, okay, what concrete facts I can experience in the outside world. Okay, I see this tree, so the tree is there and this is free of value, free of judgment or thinking. It's just recognizing, okay, there's a tree and the sun is shining and people here and so on.
The next step for Jung is Thinking, which is to characterize something, to give something a name, to say, okay, what is it? What do I think about it? Ah, this is a tree. Ah, I can recognize this. I can recognize this emotion, for example, coming up, and this is anger, fear, whatever, or happiness.
And Here he sees especially thinking as the thing that got cultivated the most in modern society. And I will also go into this later again, but this is the thinking aspect.
So this is kind of a labeling to recognize, oh, there is something that's sensation and thinking. Ah, okay, it is this. And the next step is feeling. And this is a complicated concept to explain because feeling has a lot of associations like love or tenderness or empathy and all those things.
For Jung, it's really value judgments. It's, it's like a spectrum. On the one end is something, I like something, or I don't like something on the other end of the spectrum. So it's not emotion, it's not affect, it's not love. It's really, okay, how do I stand to that? I see there is something, I can see it's a tree. Okay, what do I think about the tree?
I like the tree because it's beautiful, or I don't like the tree because it's spring and I have allergies and it's all because of the tree. This is a value judgment taking place. And the last step for Jung is the intuition aspect, which is a little bit different from sensation in the sense that sensation is very concrete.
You see the tree and it's just the tree. The intuition aspect would be to think about, okay, where's it coming from? How it will change? It's rather possibility. It's how Jung would say perceptions through the unconscious. You're perceiving things that are not really there, but could potentially be there.
This is this aspect from, okay, tree is now a bad example because for a tree, you don't have to ask yourself how it got there. But let's suppose you come into your apartment and suddenly there's a bag in the middle of the room. And of course you can realize, ah, there's a bag. This is a bag. I don't care a lot about this bag, but okay, what's going on here?
Why is there a fallen bag in my apartment? And then it's this concept of trying to find out, okay, where's something coming from or where is it going? To think of variations of possibilities. So this whole field of potential, what something could also be except for the immediate thing that it is right now.
And for intuition, Jung saw really one of the roots of creativity and also scientific endeavor. He rather saw that people have certain ideas popping up and later afterwards realizing and thinking about how they came to that conclusion.
And not thinking about something to build towards the conclusion. So those are the four functions, and those functions again are sorted in little groups, and those groups are called irrational perceptive and rational judgmental. And this has a reason for Jung.
Sensation and intuition function fall under irrational function or perceptive function, which means there's something happening outside of you, which is unstructured. When you go outside, a lot of things are happening seemingly at random, and they're just coming without any logic behind them.
So it's just an onslaught of certain things happening to you. For example, you get a phone call and something horrible has happened. It's irrational in the sense that you have not seen it coming and not everything that you're experiencing outside or inside has a connection to everything else again, but rather it's very fragmented, very separated.
And this perceptive way is really perceiving something without any evaluation. So the same way as you're perceiving something outside and you perceive it inside, you can intuit also about things without necessarily giving it a value judgment again.
And this is a, he calls it irrational part, but perceptive is maybe better understandable.
And the contrast group to that is of course the rational functions or judgmental, how we would call it, which is thinking and feeling as Thinking and feeling are two functions that are working towards a conclusion. So you're trying to find out, oh, this is something. Well, what is this? So you try to think about what it could be.
And you can also try to find out how you stand towards something. So what is my value judgment about this? Do I like it? Don't I like it? And this you could already write down in a sense and make an argument about it. So it's hard to make an argument about the things that you perceive.
You can just write it down in a descriptive manner, but about the rational functions and the rational ways, you can make an argumentation and have logical consistency. And the main difference that's separating the irrational functions and the rational functions is The rational functions can be corrected by the act of reflection.
And this is what often happens in therapy, that it gets reflected about thinking patterns or feeling patterns. And by framing things differently and thinking about things differently, you change the way and how you think about them. And, and that way. Change your demeanor and your experience and so on.
But it's strange to reflect about, to have a change of irrational experiences by reflection in the sense of irrational, just things happening to you in an unstructured way. So this was already a lot of concepts. It's extraversion, introversion, it was the four functions, and now it was those groups.
And this is the groundwork to get into the concept that Jung had of personality, which was for him, these Psychological Types, as I described, not really a system, but rather as instruments.
So he did not say that this is a way to characterize everything about a human being and say, okay, he's a thinker and he's nothing else, but rather that The personality is having a certain focus on parts.
So for the orientation, extraversion, introversion, it's the same as when you play a card game, you get a hand of cards and you start with this one. So, but this does not mean that this is the whole game.
You, of course, you play and you change and so on, but you have a certain start, starting point where you're starting from, which means that people are more inclined to an extraverted view or an introverted view just from birth. Same with the functions. He said everybody has their favorite function that came first and comes more naturally.
And this is automatically the way how people will develop first with their strongest foot and strongest hand. Same way as handedness is very common. There's a certain handedness also in these functions.
And he used it as an tool in his practice, but he very often just used it as an instrument to explain situations and behaviors. So he said, it's not like a patient comes to him and he tries to find out the type and then only cater to that type.
But rather he would use this to explain to the spouse of the patient what is happening with the wife or their husband. So this is to make it a little bit more understandable what is happening in the psyche also to others. All those things are not exclusive and they are all on a spectrum. So you tilt more towards one or the other.
And it's not like everything is— you're just extraverted, no introversion. And he also says that it's necessary to have all four. You need all four of those functions to make sense of the world and to make it understandable. Okay.
So this is the groundwork. Now, what will happen? I mentioned that there's a favorite function that everybody has, and he calls it the superior function. Superior, meaning that people tend to it first. They invest the most time in it. They're most likely also successful in that.
And if it would be possible, people would do everything in that favorite function because it becomes the most available, easiest, and successful way to interact with the world. So when you are a great thinker, you'll likely have some academic career that gives you money and makes you successful and gives you status and so on.
So of course, the valuation on thinking as a superior function is incredibly high.
And this idea to say, okay, Thinking is everything and the world is explainable by thinking and people who don't think are dumb and all the other stuff you don't really need is a limited view by the consciousness as consciousness itself is always limited and focused on a certain aspect of reality.
And this superior function plays right into it. So our consciousness is rather small and limited in capacities. So when we want to experience reality, according to Jung, we always have to focus on certain aspects. But by focusing on certain aspects, it's a little bit like light in the dark.
You fall into the trap of thinking that everything that is illuminated is everything there is, nothing else. And on the flip side of this, superior function, there's the inferior function. And for Jung, it comes down to these groups of rational and irrational functions as they are blocking each other.
They're interfering with each other. An example is the irrational functions of sensation and intuition. When you're very focused on what something is, it's harder at the same time to think about what it could be. Same if you're thinking about possibilities, it's very distracting to think about what it is.
So it's way more fun to let the mind roam freely and come up with awesome possibilities and not get bogged down by this. So this is also what he describes of intuitive people, that intuitive people have a lot of fun with just playing around with all the possibilities and everything is interesting until you have it concrete in your hand.
It's materialized as a certain possibility, then it becomes boring and dead. And so it's gets cast aside. And this is why it's always the flip side within the group that is the inferior function. So when The sensation is the superior function.
The intuitive gets into, the intuition gets into the inferior flip side way. And this means that it's incompatible with a superior function and gets ignored.
And this ignoring part leads to that it, the function is trapped in the unconscious And then the unconsciousness always means that it's very undifferentiated, very archaic, that people are not sophisticated with it because they're suddenly doing things with the wrong hand.
Normally they do things with their strong hand, but it's the same as brushing our teeth with the other hand or trying to write with the other hand. It's not sophisticated. It's rather primitive. It's embarrassing when other people see it. So people normally hide it away. Same goes for the rational functions that also are in odds with each other, which is thinking and feeling.
When you trying to think about what something is, it's very distracting to think about the same time how you think about it.
He attributed, Jung, a lot of great thinkers with a certain misogyny against women because women would steer their feeling function, and that may distract them from thinking.
Same when you are rather of a feeling type and are more into aesthetics and into beauty. It's then very distracting to think about what something is because it then robs the beauty of its magic.
So, in that sense, when thinking is superior, feeling is inferior, and the flip side around, when feeling is superior, thinking is inferior. And the groups against each other don't have such a problem, which means thinking does not influence sensation or intuition.
And other way around also. And he, C.G. Jung really shows this as a symbol of like a cross. And he would draw the line through the cross to show that there are certain functions that are inferior and in the unconscious because it has not been tended to because I'm the favorite child.
And that way, uh, complicated, at least how he said that people are trying to reach those functions that are unusual for them. And so when you are on this, your superior function, I want to get into your inferior, it can't be done directly because the field of tension is just too big.
And rather he sees it as using one of the other groups' function as an auxiliary function to use it. So to get through sensation to feeling or through intuition to feeling, then thinking is a superior function.
And the inferior function is really the fun part, the part of redemption, he's saying, because this is the part that gets ignored more. So there's the most potential for development in a human being.
And normally people are very occupied by all the personal stuff that exists. So the, the personal lives and their personal experiences and so on, and living in the certain day and time and so on.
And when they dig deeper into the unconscious, they pass this personal part of the unconscious and come into the layer, which is called the collective unconscious. Which is human nature and human experiences that existed for millions of years and even parts that are older than human beings.
So this is already the frightening part where things don't really make sense and people have weird experiences, which is also one of the reasons why the inferior function is kind of avoided because it's what's happening by using certain functions and by applying consciousness, they become differentiated and can come under the control of consciousness, which always means you can do them willfully.
You can willfully think, you can willfully feel, you can willfully sense state.
And when you don't do that, when it's practically unconscious, that means that these functions can become Autonomous, that suddenly something starts thinking in you when you not make use of it, it will get a life of its own and suddenly all those thoughts pop in the head, which happens then again automatically if it's your inferior function.
And here, this differentiation aspect is really one of separating. Certain things. Jung's view is that in the consciousness, everything is structured in an understandable way and it has cohesion and is related to each other in an understandable way.
But in the unconscious, everything is muddled. It's like really like a dark room. You don't know where one thing starts and the other one stops. So when you get one thing, you, it's like a string of clothes where you can't just put out one thing, but you pull out everything.
So when people encounter their unconscious, they become in contact with a lot of archaic images, as I said, from the collective unconscious, or also infantile material or repressed material. And this plays into the shadow aspect.
That Jung talks about and also is known for, to have these functions that are not tended to be part of the shadow, which is the flip side of consciousness. As soon as you do one thing, another thing gets ignored and falls into the shadow.
So again, it plays into this inferior function that, um, the introvert is struggling with his passions, and an extravert is hiding from his own psychology and his own unconscious and tries to always be under people so that they don't have to be alone and don't have to experience themselves.
And that a sensation-oriented person would not believe anything that they can't touch, that they can't immediately experience. As I mentioned, that a thinker is troubled by women. And feeling person is then troubled by thoughts as they can take away from this aesthetic part.
And an intuitive person hates everything that is concrete and that way shuns every time when potential really gets realized.
He also noticed that highly intuitive people have kind of a veiled look, that you're not quite sure where they're looking at, or that they rather look through things because they're experiencing all the possibilities, but not the concrete thing in front of their eyes. They're just touching the ground for very short moments.
And for Carl Gustav Jung, it always meant when you put a focus on something very hard, the other side will come through the unconscious to bring back the human being into balance.
So when the superior function goes into overdrive and limits practically everything, as there are multiple ways to experience the world, you can externally, internally, and through the four functions. When the personality is oriented in the way that it only will do experiencing one part of reality. And only in one way, all the other parts will push against it.
And this is then what's happened with neurosis, that there's a rift in the psychology and there's a disbalance, and then the unconscious will develop complexes and interfere with the function of consciousness to bring it back into a balanced state by putting the emphasis more into those parts that are disregarded.
And people already do it unconsciously by themselves. As people have a superior function and they have an orientation where they are with their birth and where they're coming from, just as a structure of their personality, they're already looking out for the other side. So very often people choose a partner which is rather the opposite from themselves.
And he says that the partner is often in the inferior function area to have still access to that area. That people are looking already for a partner that would take care of this inferior part of themselves.
So the thinker would search for a feeler so that they are covering this ground and be an approachable way into this rather unknown territory, also that people tried to pretend to be of a, another kind of the, another function.
He noticed that a lot of extroverted people would try and emulate introverted behavior by buying a pipe and getting glasses and stuff like that.
I'm not sure, right, what the connection is, but something he said in there is that people rather would not be called out on their original state of being, but rather want to communicate the stuff that is inferior to them. Also to be drawn to the— in these directions in general.
He said that when the businessman marries or tries to find some hobby that they suddenly start to get interested in music or art and so on to compensate this, because this is a rather a thing of experience that fell by the wayside. And this is already this compensation aspect.
And what for Jung life meant and living is not only that you have this personality, and this is now fixed. So you're an extraverted and you are a feeler and that's that, but rather it's a starting point and how life rather should be lived is to experience in all those different modes of experiencing and existing.
So the best way forward to develop one's psychology and to experience one's life is to go into those dark areas that are foreign and strange and weird and are common to oneself, because the highest potential lies there, because this is the area that's always got ignored.
All the stuff that has not been fitting to oneself accumulated over time. And that's a lot.
It's a lot of material because it's a lot of different ways to experience So he says the extravert needs to go into himself to develop as a person the same way as an introverted needs to go out and experience the world as an extraverted to become a well-rounded personality.
And he says that you are still limited, so you can only function in one way. It's the same as your superior function. You, you like it. You would only do things this way exactly. Even when you switch to another function, you can still only do it in this way.
Only one function after the other can be used and can be developed or differentiated, as he has been calling it. So it's really this traveling through different ways of experiencing and living the world, which he calls individuation.
As he said, this is a concrete way and most complete way of experiencing the world.
So he says the psyche and nature provides these different ways to look into the world, and you really need all those different possibilities of thinking about, experiencing rather, one thing in a thinking way, in a feeling way, and sensational way, intuitive way, and this also internally and externally, to get a grasp about one thing completely.
This is like different tools for diagnostics or building a house. Like you can't build a house only with a hammer. You also need a saw and a screwdriver and a lot of other tools, but there's not only one way how to do things. Because every function has its limits and runs into problems where it can't be solved anymore.
So the same as a company, you can't have a company that's only salespeople. You also need a company that actually produces something or does HR and so on. And here you saw the explanation why people have different personalities.
So I think every person has a different personality and it's for all the people to come together, say what they experience about the world and how they, they really see it as no experience is really objective, but rather as a sum of getting everything together is objective.
And here he saw this as this individual journey to start from a certain point. And to live through all those different functions and orientations to get to a point where one is able to have all those functions integrated into consciousness and consciously available to act in a certain way willfully.
This is why he advised against characterizing people. Like that. He took offense when other colleagues of him said, okay, you wrote the book over types and now you just make a type for everyone and all the types have a special therapy and that's it. And he said, no, that's not completely true. For one thing, he said, it's incredibly hard to get the type of a person.
It's very difficult in the sense that not everything is completely clear. It's completely possible that a person is not living in their normal state and not— so describing a type would really be describe the superior function and the starting orientation of a person.
But when people had a wrong upbringing, had to live in another function through childhood repression, let's say somebody is an extraverted, but they were never really allowed to go out. And rather were forced to cultivate this introverted view. That makes them already neurotic when they cannot work with their strong hand.
And this would already muddle it in therapy. And he said, this is typical state that somebody comes into therapy, they're neurotic, and that makes it difficult to determine what type they are because you're trying to determine by the way that a person behaves, but you don't know if it really is the consciousness and the ego of the person that's behaving like that.
As neurosis means that you have unconscious autonomous forces acting onto consciousness. So what you could experience is not really the ego, the conscious side of the person, but rather the shadow side acting up and taking control. Over the person.
And that makes it already difficult to determine what type a person really is and would also take them a lot of time, time sometimes to find out. The other side, the positive side, would be when somebody is already so well developed as a person that they have conscious control over those orientations on those functions.
This, on the other hand, is also hard to determine their type as they can use everything. So it's not clear, okay, what is their original function, the original orientation. And also this changes. He said this is not really fixed. It changes through life and the situations, what functions and ways people are living it in.
And it changes over the lifetime and also with success, you would say, which also is a situation.
At that time, psychoanalysis, when Jung was working, he had to contact a lot with Freud and there was also another one called Adler who talked about the same thing as Freud, but not from a sexuality standpoint, but from a power standpoint.
And he described the transformation of Adler as something very interesting because he seemed to be rather introverted until he got famous, and then he became very openly extroverted. And Jung noted that, okay, it seemed like he always was extroverted, but it was pushed down into the shadow.
And he had to live through not his original way and mode of being. And he also saw Freud as a neurotic and said he's rather the feeling type, but with an inferior thinking, which caused him to write all this stuff, he said jokingly.
So this again emphasizes this idea that this is not a system.
Really categorizing people, but rather to explain ways of experiencing and functioning, and also to draw out a journey for one, because this will be in the end the destiny, because the unconscious will always push for those stuff that is underdeveloped and which is in the shadow side.
So you can already say when somebody is rather in the thinking realm, that his fate and his feelings in the future will be that the feeling will constantly push against him to bring him in a balanced state and to bring in a more conscious, developed way.
And these are the immediate ideas from Jung regarding personality and the types. And it would not be Jung.
If there would not be also some freaky stuff that came out later, because this was written in the '20s and Jung lived till the '60s and he tried to connect more of those ideas later with other stuff.
Jung really tried to connect everything that is under the sun into some ideas that can be connected, starting with the psyche and all the stuff that the psyche experiences and produces, which is almost everything that humans do.
And the, let's say, freaky stuff is from astrology.
He wrote in one book that he gets sometimes when he was very unsure about the personality type of a patient, that he would get the birth date and hour, and minute to get a horoscope for them.
Because there's a whole topic about Jung and astrology, which is really interesting, and there will be an event about it in the future. But basically the idea is that year has 365 days, 24 hours, and per hour 60 minutes.
And depending on when a person is born, down to the hour and the minute, this defines their personality. So you also already have it in horoscope, but they do it on a monthly basis. There seems to be some kind of professional horoscope where you can break it down even more.
And he was— use that as a starting point for some evaluations of his patients. And of course, he was also very interested in spirituality and mythology and religion. And a very famous motif for that is the mandala. And if you know what a mandala looks like, that is that the mandala often has four parts.
And he really saw that as some kind of external validation that people knew that those four functions exist. There's 4 ways of getting information from the outside. And this was unconsciously codified in the symbol of mandalas.
And that by evaluating mandala symbols that, for example, his patients drew, that he could see the stage of individuation that they're in.
Because individuation, he said, is very closely associated to mandala visions or dreams that don't need to be a picture, but rather things in form moving on clockwise or anticlockwise rotations.
So things that must not really be understood as mandalas immediately, but rather by looking at them from a more outside perspective. And here you saw these four functions working together. So we have a very nice mandala with all of those four parts working together.
And he said when it's not four, but rather three or two, that it means that those other functions are not yet experienced and rather in the unconscious, and that their awareness is lacking in there. And this problem of something missing.
Something that you also notice with the alchemist, that they have this basic problem of three plus one.
It's really this idea of you have these functions and you can add from the other group, auxiliary group, additional functions, but there's always this residue that you can't integrate because it's too foreign and too strange.
And this is the inferior function because it's too dissimilar from everything else that he found as a problem also in alchemy and also in the Christian church and the cross. Not in the cross exactly, but in the Trinity, that it's only three and the fourth is missing. And the fourth, of course, it's the feminine aspect.
So there's always trouble with the fourth. And he found this motif in different areas and documented all of this.
And this symbolism goes further for him when you go into mythology, that you can say, okay, human beings, developing as a species started in a very unconscious state, similar as children, but more and more consciousness became active.
And that this got codified in mandalas or pairs of four. In the early time in Egypt, when you had the four sons of Horus, where only one of the sons had a human head, but the other one had animal heads. Calling for an animalistic nature because they are unconscious and not integrated and cannot be willfully used.
And in that way are strange, strange and separated like animals and not human beings. And that this development of consciousness, psyche and humanity brought more and more functions under willful control through culture, through institutions.
And especially favored thinking in the modern world, that there's a lot of this way of thinking about and experiencing the world.
And he criticizes that as that there's, of course, then again, the feeling, the moral part is missing, that there's really this cold intellect looking at the world and rather thinking what is possible and what can be done and how to do it, and not questioning if something should be done.
So this age-old dream of humans flying immediately led to humans bombing cities and towns. That this moral aspect is missing, that it's normally happening more in the feeling aspect of evaluating if something is good or bad.
And you notice that Jung tries to connect a lot of different things, starting with the psychology and starting from the fact that there's always been psychology with human beings around and that human beings are still similar, that we are not completely separated from that, how we were thousands, tens of thousands, or millions of years ago.
But rather that they are now products of culture and of education. But deep down, all of these things are still working and happening, and the requirements and demands of society are still the same to push people in a certain direction and to be.
But today, he says, consciousness is so prevalent and has a so strong grip on experience that nothing else is allowed in. But the more you ignore the other stuff, the more it pushes, the more psychological problems happen, he says.
And also the more unhappy are people because it's always stuff missing that should normally be there and be used. So This would be my presentation for personality and psychological types and all the implications that Carl Gustav Jung saw for that. And I hope it was understandable, and I hope that it was entertaining.
And I'm pretty sure there are still a lot of questions because I just grazed some things from the side. So I'm going to drink something, and if somebody wants to say something, feel free.